am morgen ist es endlich soweit
heiligabend und natürlich wird es ein
fest dass etwas anders ist als wir es
bisher kannten wir alle versuchen es so
möglich sicher zu machen mit den engsten
verwandten aber ich denke wir beide und
viele andere werden noch fragen haben
wie man das jetzt am besten gestaltet
und genau darüber wollen wir jetzt am
abend vor heiligabend noch einmal
sprechen uns zugeschaltet dr thomas
aßmann jetzt dass man sie beantworten
für uns jetzt einige zuschauer fragen
damit wir alle etwas beruhigter dann in
die festtage gehen können die allererste
frage kommt von sa die kaputte ri aus
hannover ein wunderschönen guten abend
herr professor aber ich hätte zwei
fangen sie erst mal würde ich gerne
wissen wie feiern sie zu hause mit ihrer
familie weihnachten unter welchen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen tun sie das und die
zweite frage wäre weil die schüler ja in
unterricht in den schulen auch die
masken tragen welche regeln würde zu
hause dafür dann wegfallen ich wünsche
ein frohe weihnachten bleiben sie alle
gesund und macht und der zuschauer
thorsten wir würden ganz kurz die
antwort erstmal abwarten
auf diese fragen helgason
ok also erstmal glaube ich müsste mich
dann ein bisschen herum style sowie sie
an gekleidet sind
jetzt kriegt ja doch noch am tisch aber
ist es dann so wie feiern mit komplotten
insgesamt mit genügend abstand etwa wir
versuchen ein meter fünfzig einzuhalten
dann natürlich auch haben wir uns selber
abgetrennt getestet dass wir also ein
crooner frei sind es werden denn noch
machen bzw ist schon erfolgt wir sind
soweit auch eine reservation das ist
also kein thema dass wir da auch keinen
anstecken und ich denke das wird kein
großes problem sein wir sind da im alter
um die 50 bis drei jüdischen oder einmal
20 jährige
es ist so das hauptproblem natürlich
dann sagen werden wenn wir zu machen
seinen eltern fahren
das ist so dass meine frau zu ihren
eltern fahren wird und ich fahre zu
meinen eltern
normalerweise wären wir immer zusammen
aber das machen dieses jahr getrennt und
wie gesagt vorher achten wir darauf dass
wir halt in eine isolation sind dass wir
nicht erkältet sind kein
erkennungszeichen uns körperlich fit
sind und wie gesagt vorher ausgetestet
sind bei den schülern muss man natürlich
so sagen wir sollten wir jetzt auch eine
woche lang in quarantäne gewesen sein
ich kann mich erinnern als ich noch mal
18 war habe ich das natürlich auch
gemacht weil dann braucht eine woche zu
hause vor weihnachten bald sie fragen
oder immun sicher ist dann sollten sich
vielleicht doch noch mal gucken ob sie
eben schnell test kriegen und bei den
erkältungs anzeichen wenn sie in welche
erkältungs zeichen haben als ich mir
also sollte dann werde ich ganz
vorsichtig ich ganz dramatisch sein
sollte dass sie unbedingt jetzt so der
doch am küchentisch oder am essenstisch
dabei sein wollen usw
sie haben wirklich angst dann wäre es
vielleicht sinnvoll rp zwei maske zu
tragen wenn sie hat angst haben die ich
könnte übertragung keinen test mehr
gekriegt habe und da gewisse
unsicherheit ist das zwar nicht ganz so
romantisch gibt es zu aber große
sicherheit und wie gesagt ein meter
fünfzig abstand und da haben wir gesagt
mit dem singen mit dem weihnachtssingen
würde ich auch zurückhaltend sein
also von mir aus der natur aus weil ich
kein großer sänger bin aber ich glaube
ganz wichtig ruhig das singen kommt sehr
viel arioso ja deswegen sollte man
dieses jahr auf weihnachten also stille
nacht lang verzichten soll sich sprechen
also bei mir in der familie alle singen
so können wir es nicht so schlimm der
einzige der sich und da will niemand
zuhören aber doktor als mann thorsten
bosse aus göttingen hat eine frage und
zwar denn deine würde seine
dreieinhalbjährige tochter gerne ihre
großmutter sehen gibt es irgendwelche
tipps die sie haben damit ein kleines
kind doch noch seine großeltern sehen
kann gibt es irgendwo vorsichtsmaßnahmen
die sie daher empfehlen können
die tochter sollte er eine woche
vorlagen auch in quarantäne
bei den eltern und so weiter wenn ich
davon ausgehen kann dass das kind also
in einem umfeld war kein koma erreger
war wo keine cola ausbruch war und es in
dem moment wo es jetzt auch zu den
großeltern pferd corona fieber fall ist
erkältungszeit keine geltung symptomen
dann denke ich können sie gutes gewissen
zu den großeltern fahren
ich bin noch ganz ehrlich sie werden nie
eine hundertprozentige sicherheit finden
ja man muss ganz klar wir können das
risiko minimieren muss auch ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass wir das monieren aber
ich glaube einfach wenn das kind
wirklich eineinhalb jahre ist es war
eine woche lang zu hause ist hat keinen
kontakt zu patienten gehabt
es ist schieber freiherr karl schnupfen
und sollte dann würde ich auch alle
verletzten großeltern war
wenn jetzt noch eine frage von mike
adams von aus langenzenn gerade jetzt
bei dem ein und spaziergängen die wege
sind enger
es kommen wir personen gegen die pocken
die fahrrad fahren reicht da eineinhalb
meter abstand oder sind die module
erhöht und ich muss tatsächlich darauf
achten dass ich mehr abstand zu der
person haben gerade jetzt war die
meinung spazierte die frage stellen wir
gleich zweimal denn die ist natürlich
nicht nur an den feiertagen wichtig wir
wollen das ganze aber noch mal von herrn
doktor assmann natürlich hören was macht
man jetzt am besten ist natürlich nicht
nur ein heiliger abend oder den
festtagen eine frage wenn man auf der
straße nicht genug platz hat um
auszuweichen
also normalerweise rollen normalerweise
ist die ansteckungsgefahr ist ein extrem
gering
einfach deswegen weil auch solange die
lehren aus halten punkten aus dieser
eigenart meter abstand zu hingegen haben
es ist so dass durch die lüfte ist eben
eine luftzirkulation da ist ja wie
russland mitgetragen wird also die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich im freien
anzustecken extrem gering gerade nehmen
sie ein meter fünfzig abstand halten
wenn sie wirklich ängstlich sind und
sagen ich bin ganz vorsichtig sein
dann können sie in der alltags massa
kurz oder ziel mit den themen
entgegenkommt also ich würde das so
machen wir bei uns erwartet
diese ausfällt sich dann nach dem essen
abends wahrscheinlich dann doch noch mal
für die unsere kirche hinziehen werde
und dann nochmal beziehungsweise nur ein
bisschen nachdenken werde
auch ins freie und ins freie zu gehen
ich glaube das ist kein
sicherheitsgewinn worden vielen dank dr
thomas erstmal wir wünschen ihnen und
ihre verwandte durch sehr besinnlich und
vor allem sehr gesunde weihnachtstage
dankeschön bleibt es schön negativ